here we have a little block that sits on
that surface and well what can one do
with the block you can pour [ __ ] or you
can pull it and that's exactly what
we're going to look at now so I can
exert a pushing force onto this block
here push um but I could also pull it
like this F pull and the question is how
can we formalize this a little bit more
we can now also look at a small piece of
rope or a string and you know I could in
a tug-of-war I'm going to pull here and
I'm also going to pull here and we'll
see who's gonna win so we have two
pulling forces here on on either side in
a slightly different scenario where
we're going to put both of these things
together we have a block here sitting on
a surface and we have a little string
attached to it and let's say we have a
pulley here and the string goes around
there and there's a little mass hanging
here we we want to now describe what
this force is here that's pulling things
and for that we have to look at what's
going on in that little string so let's
draw another string and this is this is
our string and let's take an imaginary
cut right through the middle here and
I'm gonna draw both pieces here this is
the left part and here is the right part
and what's what's happening in in this
rope you know well there is a force
acting on the left object due to the
interaction with the right one
and here we have a force on the right
one due to the interaction with the left
piece and that of course happens
anywhere you know I take a cut here
along the line
and we can even formalize that a little
bit more by just placing our coordinate
system here and let's say X equals zero
here and so for all X along this line we
always have these pairs of forces so
there are an interaction pair and if I
look at the rope from afar there they
will cancel out but if I look at what's
going on inside the Rope then this is
what they are and we know from Newton's
third law that f RL equals minus F L R
so the forces of of set of the same
magnitude or but the opposite direction
if there weren't the same then my rope
would would get in trouble but what we
wanted to find now actually is tension
the tension force that is a long that's
happening along this rope here in our
tug-of-war you know someone pulls from
the outside and for that we first going
to look at the magnitude of our
interaction pair here F RL and that of
course equals the magnitude of F L R and
we're actually going to define now this
magnitude here as the tension force and
that is true for all X along this line
here that we have this the magnitude
that this is the magnitude of this force
here and from now on we're going to call
when we call it when we talk about
tension in a rope and we talk about the
magnitude of one of these internal
forces here